M: Are you ready?
T: I am ready!
T: I-i'm i'm just gonna yell go!
Okay
Go!  *Genie noise*
WOAH!
Who rubbed my lamp?!
I rubbed your lamp!
Are you sure it wasn't him?
I'm-I'm a known rubber but I don't wanna do any of that.
E: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Phil, I knew that was bad luck when you told me to rub that lamp!
I know! There's this GIANT....
MAGIC
SEA MONSTER!
I'm called a genie!
I'm called a genie.
SEA MONSTER!
IT'S CALLED A GENIE, YOU IDIOT!
Have you seen Aladdin?
Same-same principle.
But he said Phil. He said you told him to rub  it.
I can only give the wishes to whoever rubbed it.
This is like the crucially important step.
*he's excited now* I get any wish I want?
MAKE HIM SHORTER THAN ME!
LOOK!
J-ooooohn???
*audience laughs*
YOU'VE KNOWN ME FOR 6 YEARS, YOU DON'T M-MA MA MA NAME!!
John.
I wanna be TALLER than you!
No, make him shorter than me!
Don't make me taller, I'm good where I am.
But make him shorter!
Are you sure you don't wanna be taller?
*Audience laughs again*
*WAS THAT A SHORT JOKE?*
*TRIGGERED*
*SNAPS*
I WANT YOU TO BE SHORTER!
M: I wish for you to be shorter!
E: He can't-
B: That's not how this works
T: YOU'RE OUT OF TIME!
Oh.
*Now, they start laughing*
*BEEP*
YOU'RE A SEA MONSTER!
B: I'm a genie who rubbed me?
M:I'm a known rubber. I rub you so good.
I rubbed. I RUBBED!
MAKE YOU SHORTER!
I RUBBED!
GET IN THE LAMP!
*BEEP*
*QUICK GENIE NOISE*
B: RUB ME!
M: I'M TALL!
*BACK TO REALITY!*
*They're all laughing now.*
*Crowd cheering!*
BACK THAT A$$ UP!
QUICK, GO SUBSCRIBE TO LIXIAN THE ANIMATOR!
AND MARK IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY!
LINK TO THE ORIGINAL ON THE LEFT OR DESC.
THANKS FOR READING THE SUBTITLES!
HAVE A GREAT DAY/NIGHT!
AND I WILL SEE YOU
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH BYE!!!!<3 :3
Okay...